Welcome back. Now, there's been
an odd phenomena
happening in the Trump campaign,
and I'm not talking about
the Trump campaign.
Uh, it's about
some of his followers.
And you have a lot of
black people supporting Trump.
Um, black people
supporting Trump?
(exclaiming)
So, where are
these black people?
Well, I had some of them
in my studio the other day,
uh, where I asked them
the simple question:
what the (bleep)
are you thinking?
I just want to ask
a very straight question
from the beginning. Um,
why do you support Donald Trump?
I'm a registered Democrat,
let me start first,
and I lost faith
and belief in the current state
of our party right now
with our two candidates.
I'm open to Donald Trump
because I feel like,
um, he's a gangster.
-He's a gangster?
-He's a gangster.
Is he a gangster or gangsta?
-He's a gangsta.
-Okay.
He's going out here
and he's kind of gangstering
the whole situation.
He's like,
"If you come up to my mic,
you know, I'm taking you out."
-Right. -Coming from
the hip-hop community,
I understand his language.
Right, because
he is kind of like a rapper.
-I mean, he's into gold.
-That's what I'm saying.
-Right? He has his own vodka.
-Absolutely.
-Uh, he's got a private jet.
-That's right.
-And he really likes
white women. -Exactly.
-And his wife was a model.
-Correct.
Would that sway anybody else--
those qualities?
The way you express it--
I-I never thought of it
that way, you know,
but he's pretty cool.
Have you told other black people
you're voting for Donald Trump?
-Be honest. -Yeah, absolutely.
-Absolutely.
Kevin, be honest.
Have you told family members?
-I've told family members, I've
told... -You've told your mama
-that you're voting for...
-I told my wife...
-that I'm... We fight
every morning about it. -Mm-hmm.
But I stand on my own, too.
This is America.
America is greedy.
America is going to try
to cut corners,
so we have to make a place
for ourselves.
So, Donald Trump
is the president
who can get black people
those low-paying jobs again.
No, we don't want
the low paying jobs.
Lower-paying jobs are
the first rung on the ladder
so you can't-you can't
climb up the ladder
-till you start someplace.
-Donald Trump will get
black people back on that
first rung of the ladder.
If you're on the ladder here,
you're gonna climb up more.
Should the Mexicans
be allowed to use that ladder
-to climb the wall?
-Yes. -Most definitely.
Not the wall...
Do you have a message
for other black people out there
telling them why they might
want to vote for Donald Trump?
I'll just...
I would say just know that
Donald Trump is not gonna
make you a slave.
-He's not gonna make you
a slave? -He's not gonna
make you a slave,
you're not gonna be
-back in the cotton fields. -And
you're sure about that, Gary?
-I'm pretty sure about that.
-Okay.
-Everybody's trying
to enslave you. -Mm-hmm.
But the main important thing
is how much I'm gonna get paid
-while I'm enslavement,
you know? -Mm-hmm.
So, you're pro-slavery
but with pay.
-That's right, that's right.
-You're anti-slavery.
Yeah, anti-slavery. -Okay,
anyone else pro-slavery here?
Donald Trump says he has a great
relationship with the blacks.
Okay, as one of the blacks,
how would you describe
that relationship?
-The fact that he says "the
blacks"... -"The blacks", right.
...means that his relationship
is a little skewed,
because he wouldn't
call us "the blacks"
if he really understood
where we were coming from.
Does it feel like he's
in an abusive relationship
with the blacks?
Are you guys
secretly trying
to get out of this relationship?
-Not at all. -Okay, so how did
you guys feel when Trump said
he wants to ban Muslims
from coming into the country?
-We don't have any Muslims
here, right? -I'm Muslim.
-You're kidding me.
-No, I'm not kidding you.
-And you're gonna vote
for Trump? -Most certainly.
-Really?
-Yes.
Would you be opposed, uh,
to having Trump waterboard you
just to get more information
about Islam?
-Um... -If Trump came in here
and he had to pick one person
to waterboard,
who do you think he would pick?
Rhymes with schmuslim?
Um...
Let's pretend like
I'm your father, okay?
You guys are all my kids
and you have to convince me
-that I should vote for
Donald Trump, okay? -Absolutely.
Hey, kids, how's it going?
Why do you guys...
Why are you guys all here?
What's going on?
Dad, we're about to vote for
Donald Trump, and we need you...
Jenay, you're so funny.
Jenay is always the funniest
member of this family.
All right, you guys want to go
to the movies tonight?
-What do you want to do? I'm
sorry? -No, we need you to...
we need you to cast
your vote as well.
-What are you talking about?
-Because we can't just
-be Democrats because
we're black. -That's right.
Wait, hold on.
Winston, you believe this, too?
I believe her 100%.
(bleep), please. Come on,
what's going on in here?
Are you voting for Trump
because, as an Orange-American,
he's the only remaining
candidate of color?
I'm tired of the jokes.
Stop the jokes on Donald Trump.
You guys know
I'm a fake journalist, right?
Absolutely.
What kind of disturbs me
in some of these rallies is
you guys have seen this,
where Trump gets everybody
to make a pledge?
Have you seen that?
Where he has them
pledge to vote for him?
I just want you guys
to raise your hand
and we'll just
take a pledge right now.
Okay. And, um, just say,
I will never
tell black people...
I will never tell
black people...
...that I am voting
for Donald Trump...
...that I am
voting for Donald Trump...
...until after the election.
...until after
the election.
I love the fact that, uh,
you spoke so freely
and passionately about this.
And, uh, thanks for coming.
-Pleasure having us. -Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
I still don't get it.
We'll be right back.